[Music]
from this result consciousness must go
on still further in its contradictory
movement and of necessity again
dissemble this suppression of moral
action morality is the in itself the
merely implicit element if it is to be
actual the final purpose of the world
cannot be fulfilled
rather the moral consciousness must
exist on its own account and find itself
confronted by in nature opposed to it
but it must be perfected at its own self
this leads to the second postulate of
the harmony of itself and the nature
which is immediately an element in it
that is the sense nature moral
self-consciousness asserts that its
purpose is pure is independent of
inclinations and impulses which implies
that it has eliminated within itself
sensuous purposes but this alleged
elimination of the element of sense its
assembles again
it acts brings its purpose into actual
existence and the self conscious sense
nature which is supposed to be
eliminated is precisely this middle term
or mediating element between pure
consciousness and actual existence it is
the instrument or organ of the former
for its realization and what is called
impulse inclination moral
self-consciousness is not therefore in
earnest with the elimination of
inclination and impulses for it is just
these that are the self realizing self
consciousness but also they ought not to
be suppressed but only to be in
conformity with reason and they are in
conformity with reason for moral action
as nothing else but consciousness
realizing itself thus giving itself the
shape of an impulse that is it is
immediately the present harmony of
impulse and morality but impulse is not
in fact merely this empty shape which
could have within it a spring of action
other than the one it is and be impelled
by it for sense nature is one which
contains within itself its own laws and
springs of action consequently morality
cannot therefore be an earnest about
being itself the mainspring of impulses
the angle of inclination for
inclinations for since these have their
own fixed quality and peculiar content
the consciousness to which they were to
conform would rather would be rather in
conformity with them a conformity with
which moral self-consciousness refuses
to comply the harmony of the two is thus
merely implicit merely postulated in
moral action the actually present
harmony of morality and the sense nature
was just that was just now asserted but
now is displaced the harmony is beyond
consciousness and a nebulous remoteness
where nothing can anymore be accurately
distinguished or comprehended for our
attempt just now to comprehend this
unity failed in this merely implicit
harmony however consciousness surrenders
itself altogether this implicit harmony
is its moral perfection where the
struggle of morality in the sense nature
is ceased and the latter is in
conformity with morality in a way that
is beyond our comprehension for that
reason this perfection is again only at
assemblance a falsification of the
situation since as a matter of fact it
would be rather morality itself that was
given up in that perfection because it
is only consciousness of absolute
purpose is pure purpose one therefore
opposed to all other purposes morality
is both the activity of this pure
purpose and also the consciousness of
rising above sense nature of being mixed
up with sense nature and struggling
against it that consciousness is not in
earnest about the perfection of morality
is indicated by the fact that
consciousness itself shifts it away into
infinity that is asserts that the
perfection is never perfected
paragraph 622 is quite a lengthy
paragraph there's a lot going on in this
section and notice how often Hegel uses
the term that in fact provides the title
for this entire section decembe Lance or
duplicity both of which are translations
of fish telling which has this notion of
putting something out there setting it
down
Stalin right but doing so in a way that
conceals or falsifies and what is being
falsified here it's the relationship of
consciousness with itself fundamentally
but also with the world you could call
this in in many respects a metaphysical
deception of oneself understanding here
metaphysical not just simply in terms of
you know the big things like time and
causality but the metaphysics of the
human person what we sometimes call
philosophy of action although at times
that loses its its metaphysical
grounding and in this section in this
paragraph Hegel is setting out for us
and kind of summarizing at this point
the ways in which self-consciousness
rational self-consciousness spirit
moving itself has managed to
misunderstand misrepresent to itself the
relation between it on the one hand and
then these two we might call them
polarities of morality and actuality on
the other hand how does it bring those
together and you know we've seen that
there's a lot of ways in which it
misunderstands Duty and how that works
and all these postulates and harmony
there is going to be something else
that's also productive here as well and
notice that Hegel at several points in
this also uses that term of Abel the
here it's translated
you know suppression but anytime that we
see out of a bond we should think not
just you know an erasure or suppression
or repression or getting rid of
something but that there's something
also being preserved from it something
being distilled from it so this one
begins with Hegel talking about this
results right from this result
consciousness must go on still further
in its contradictory movement and he
means a movement of and through
contradiction vitas Brookley right and
what is this this movement he says this
is a contradictory movement that of
necessity will dissemble the suppression
of moral action more Alicia haand look
comportment behavior however you want to
understand action here it's not just an
action it is action with a you might say
capital a understood as a whole way of
comporting oneself of being within the
world
so he says morality here's where our
first step in this process is morality
is the in itself the merely implicit
element it needs to be brought to light
it needs to be worked through right and
so he says if it is going to be actual
if it's going to be something of the
world vehicle eek if it's going to be
brought into reality rather than merely
being an ideal that we espouse and talk
about how great it is and say wouldn't
it be nice if we were moral morality
part of the drive behind it that we've
seen in the previous section is if we're
gonna talk about morality at all it's
already got to sort of drive to it that
it should be actual but it isn't actual
yet so he goes on and he says if it's
going to be actual as we've seen in the
previous paragraphs then the final
purpose of the world cannot be fulfilled
so that's paradoxical isn't it if we're
going to follow the should the lot then
somehow we lose track of the end the
purpose butts vac that should be
inhabiting that should I've used a lot
of shoulds in that sentence let me
rephrase that on the one hand we have
over here morality with its imperatives
with it's telling us what to do not just
saying it would be a good idea if you
were to do this it's saying do this
you ought to behave this way on the
other hand if we do in fact behave that
way and we fulfill the purpose of
morality we lose the final purpose
that's an act the end what it is that
we're trying to strive for of the world
the morality in a way goes astray a
little bit later in this paragraph Hegel
is going to talk about a displacement
and that's actually a good term for
thinking about what happens here earlier
in the paragraph we have all of these
displacements these slippage --is so he
goes out and he says rather the moral
consciousness must exist on its own
account and find itself confronted by a
nature opposed to it what is this nature
the nature of the world the way things
work the physical world right where we
have to overcome say physical pain and
hardship and transform it through our
labor but even more than that you could
say the social and cultural and
political world where things aren't fair
where morality although it exists and
lots of people give lip service to it
has not become actual where in fact it's
been subverted where most people don't
behave like decent human beings at least
a good portion of the time and a lot of
the people when they do they're secretly
plotting how they might get away with
not behaving that way or they're
chuckling to themselves about the fact
that they managed to pull off aid
assemblance of their foul base motives
sort of like Kant's shopkeeper who gives
the fair price and is thinking to
himself you bastards
if I could cheat you I would
Kant doesn't say that but you could well
imagine somebody like that so he says
the moral consciousness must find itself
confronted by a nature opposed to it
without that opposition of nature
there's no resistance there's no raw
material on which moral consciousness
can actually operate and perfect itself
and build itself and show itself show
itself in its essence so he goes on and
he says moral consciousness must be
perfected in its own self so this leads
us he says to this second postulate of a
harmony right a harmony of what the
harmony of itself
moral consciousness and the nature which
is immediately an element in it now we
can understand the nature as being the
natural world we can also understand the
nature as being human nature in the
sense where we say oh well that's just
human nature everybody's kind of a jerk
right people are all out for themselves
that's nature but then nature is also
within me if I'm being honest with
myself as a moral being I have to own up
to the fact that the reason I don't
measure up is because I have all of this
as Kant would put it and other thinkers
as well
sensuous nature that drives me in
certain ways as a matter of fact this is
not just something of German idealism
and Kant this goes all the way back
through early modern philosophy you're
gonna find this in Descartes you're
gonna find this in other thinkers and it
goes into medieval philosophy it goes
all the way back to ancient philosophy
this notion that our sensuous nature
leads us to have all these desires and
drives and impulses that are not really
rational and although they can be made a
harness by or you know brought under the
sway of Reason and they get us into
trouble and that's part of me that's
what I carry around inside of me all the
time I am a pleasure seeking being
like it or not I am a pain avoiding
being like it or not I care about what
my neighbor thinks of me even if it's
about stupid things that shouldn't
really matter to me we could go on and
on and on with examples of this sensuous
nature right so there's a reconciliation
here a postulated harmony but it's
postulated that doesn't mean that it
actually is the case so he says moral
self-consciousness asserts that its
purpose is pure right I'm a good person
I'm gonna do the right thing I
understand what my duties are I'm going
to fulfill them and then I've got this
other part of myself that I got to kind
of whip a bit you know or you know punch
into shape and make it do the right
stuff sort of like thing about Plato's
tripartite soul right reason and then
you've got that thematic part and that
through monic part is saying appetites
get in line knock it off right that's
what's happening and we could you know
look at other moral anthropology's
besides that at Plato we can look at
that of Khan we could look at that as
Spinoza we could look at that of
Aristotle we could look at that of the
Stoics and you're gonna keep seeing the
same thing the higher part needs to do
the right thing and those lower parts
keep getting in the way and screwing
things up so do we really have a harmony
no we we experience something quite
different
he says moral self-consciousness tries
to tell itself something that's not true
it says that its purpose is pure it is
independent of inclinations and impulses
it says I can imagine myself being
independent of inclinations and impulses
therefore I am actually so but this is
where it gets really really interesting
put in another anthropology our rational
faculty is shot through and through with
inclination and impulses that come to it
partly from its sensuous nature and it's
lying to itself in pretending that
that's not the case so all
that repression all of that shoving it
down you appetites get in line that's
gonna be counterproductive isn't it he
goes on and he says this alleged
elimination of the element of cents it
dissembles again moral consciousness he
says acts it brings a purpose that's vac
a goal into actual existence and he says
the self-conscious sense nature which is
supposed to be eliminated
that winds up being the third mediating
term the if you like to say at the not
the weakest link in the chain the
strongest link in the chain the thing
that binds these together pure
consciousness actual existence since you
know nature whatever that's going to be
these impulses these inclinations that's
the thing that actually binds them
together otherwise you just be some
disembodied pure consciousness floating
around out there thinking great thoughts
to yourself and never actually
coinciding with this messy reality of
actual existence that calls upon for us
to act action requires Hegel is pointing
out to us a sense nature it's
inescapable you might say a ghost in the
sense of a spook can't act Geist
spirit can however act acting through
the real world that it inhabits that
it's a node with it all right come back
to the to the text now so he says it's
the mediating element between pure
consciousness and actual existence since
nature he says is the instrument or the
organ of the former and what is the
former pure consciousness it is how pure
consciousness can actually do anything
including he doesn't say this here but
think about this including understanding
itself as pure consciousness there is no
map of the mind that isn't a map which
rely
looking at things of the world and
analogizing from that does that mean
that it's solely reducible the way
materialists would like to say no but
this is a sort of higher level
materialism you could say than that of
vulgar accrued reductive materialism so
back to the text again he says moral
self-consciousness is not being honest
in earnest
Ernst right it's not being honest with
itself about the elimination the ALF hey
bong of inclinations and impulses
nagging right leaning towards something
and hey Cleve drives impulses now why is
this important you know you can
understand these again in terms of the
appetites in a sort of platonic or even
Aristotelian sense you can also
understand this in terms of Kant's own
language of dealing with nagging
inclination desire right and drives
impulses liebe right
all of those are irrational they're
they're not rational yet you might say
they can be brought under the sway of
practical reason and that's where we're
heading with this but they they haven't
been so yet so we should be suspicious
of them and yet we have to have them in
order to do anything
so he says moral self-consciousness is
actually realizing itself with them he
says it is just these it is just our
impulses and inclinations that are the
self realizing self-consciousness now
let's pause there for just a second I
realize that we're going a little long
with this but what does it mean to say
that we wouldn't just have an
inclination or an impulse but that
inclination or impulse is me is me as a
moral actor not the totality of me but
something much more essential than just
something that I happen to suffer or
have something that is at the core of
who I am
it is my self-consciousness
self-realizing making itself real what
is that like that means that my hunger
my desire for recognition you know on
our Kenan Hegel my sexuality my you know
arrangement of where I fit into the
social hierarchy even the things that
seemed like completely irrational whims
all of those would go into my you might
say moral composition as an agent within
the world so he goes on and he says
these ought not to be suppressed but
here's another model we've moved to
another place they ought to be brought
in conformity with reason and isn't that
what we see in ancient and medieval and
even much early modern moral psychology
and ethics reason is there for us it's
not fully rational necessarily our
Faculty of reason can be damaged it can
be infected with vices it can be you
know shot through with all sorts of
screwy fantasy eye appearances it may
need some perfection may be damaged by
original sin you know come up with all
sorts of things but it's there and
however good it happens to be what we
want to do is take all that other stuff
that we've got all those drives
inclination desires all these appetites
and bring them under the sway of reason
at least as much as we can and that is
going to be moral motivation which is
going to lead to moral action so he says
but these are actually in conformity
with reason see because moral action is
nothing else but consciousness realizing
itself and he says here's something very
important realizing it self means giving
itself the shape the Gestalt of an
impulse the form of an impulse
the mindset of an impulse he says its
immediately the present harmony of
impulse and morality so it sounds like
everything's been solved right way this
is so wonderful we we finally arrived at
the point where you know all these
harmonies they didn't work out
maybe now we do in fact have a harmony
that lasts we can bring everything into
one clean picture we can end the section
no not so fast we can't even end the
paragraph yet he says impulse is not in
fact this empty shape which could have
within it a spring of action other than
the one it is and be impelled by it once
you actually get on the impulse train
it's not quite so simple as to just say
well reason will dictate where you go I
mean the train for what is this metaphor
the train has its tracks where it's
going right and the conductor he can
like he or she can you know blow the
whistle they can you know say put more
coal in or wood or whatever it's gonna
be or diesel you know they can control
that that lever and say more of this and
he can pull the brakes but and if he
gets to you know a place ahead where he
could actually control the juncture
maybe he could actually exercise some
choice there but he usually has to
signal to the guy down the end who's
gonna like you know turn the thing and
make the train go this way but you're
not gonna like turn it like you are a
car and go off the tracks that's just
not the way it works with a train
alright so that's actually a good
metaphor for this so he says since
nature is one which contains within it
its own laws its own gazettes a-- and
its own springs of action consequently
says morality cannot be in earnest about
being the mainspring of impulses the
angle of inclination for inclinations it
can't actually bend the inclinations
that can't you know incline them the
right way we have another decembe lence
don't we whenever you're not being an
earnest your dissembling so he says
since these impulse
nations have their own fixed quality and
peculiar content you might even say
psychological laws the consciousness to
which they were to conform would rather
be in conformity with them and this is
something that we do experience give in
to the inclination give in to the
impulse the impulse the inclination
takes over and decides for you there's
an old expression you know talking about
how people develop certain vices at
first the man drinks the drink and then
after a while the drink drinks the drink
and then the drink you know determines
the man and pretty soon there's really
you could just take the man out of the
circuit altogether except for the fact
that you need arms and legs and that
sensuous nature but there's there's a
driving that's going on as a matter of
fact if any of you ever watch that show
trailer park boys there's a great
illustration of this in the character
mr. lahey who over and over again as the
show progresses and he declines further
and further into an alcoholism that's
almost of legendary proportions and
difficult to see how it would would
possibly be feasible for a human being
to take that much abuse through through
alcohol he talks about letting the
liquor do the thinking he runs into
conundrums and then he says I just need
to you know down a fifth and then the
liquor will do the thinking for me and
impulses you could say work much the
same way we talk you know and very you
know sort of silly terms for men about
letting the little head do the thinking
for the big head and what are we talking
about they're allowing the impulse of
sexual desire to determine what our
reasoning processes are going to be we
could talk this way about all sorts of
impulses and desires so he says again
the consciousness to which they were to
conform the moral consciousness would
rather be in conformity with them a
conformity with which moral
consciousness self consciousness refuses
to comply so we have a disagreement
there the person can resist and say no
no that's not good and he says we have
again a postulated harmony so he says
in moral action now we're in the second
half of this paragraph the actually
present harmony of morality in the sense
nature was just now asserted but it gets
displaced the harmony is beyond
consciousness in a nebulous remoteness
where nothing can anymore be accurately
distinguished or comprehended
why are you says our attempt to
comprehend this unity fail we haven't
succeeded in bringing it an
intelligibility that actually ties
together morality and since nature we
certainly had some stands at it this
isn't a pure a Perea where we just like
throw the cards in the air and say games
over we've learned something on the way
we've learned that you know
consciousness has been hiding things
from itself and if we identify ourselves
with this movement as we should we
probably learned something about
ourselves on the way as well so he says
in this merely implicit harmony
consciousness surrenders itself
altogether this implicit harmony is its
moral perfection where the struggle of
morality and sense nature has ceased and
the ladders in conformity with morality
now notice what he says in a way that is
beyond our comprehension
now if Hegel were not Hegel he might at
that point say all right that's where we
stop we've reached the you know limits
of our understanding we've reached the
limits of what reason can teach us this
is where Hegelian idealism is something
a bit different
Hegel will take every limit of that sort
every assertion of not being able to be
comprehended of in intelligibility as a
challenge that is to be surmounted now
that doesn't mean that any particular
individual will do so but in the course
of world history in the development of
morality as people think this through
somebody will make sense of it and
proceed through it
that'll come a little bit later looks
linger with this so he says for this
reason this perfection this harmony was
only a
dissemblers a falsification of the
situation because he says as a matter of
fact it would be rather morality itself
that was given up in that perfection
because it is only consciousness of
absolute purpose as pure purpose
therefore as opposed to other purposes
what does he mean there moral action
right of pure consciousness would be
action that is guided by a purpose it's
vac and the purpose itself would be to
further morality to bring morality into
the world however in doing so it would
be running smack-dab into all these
other other purposes alternate purposes
which don't actually match up or map on
to the purpose of morality they haven't
been reconciled yet they haven't been
harmonized yet the attempt to say well
reason can encompass all of them and
figure all this out didn't work yet so
he says morality is both the activity of
this pure purpose but also the
consciousness of rising above sense
nature of being mixed up with sense
nature and struggling against it so if
you lose that struggle you lose morality
by winning morality loses so you always
need to have a little bit of stuff in
the background to struggle against
fortunately for most of us we have more
than enough we'd only have a little
benefit we have plenty of it and it's
confusing as hell and complicated and
it's like an onion you know or the
proverbial you peel away the layers and
we find another one underneath we're
like oh I dealt with that trauma
oh I dealt with that vise oh I figured
out what the hell's wrong with me that
I'd do this thing and I respond this way
and then there's yet another one
underneath that you got to work at so
good news okay if we think about things
this way so he says the goal would be
for for consciousness that is
progressing towards perfection
as morality would be what he says the
consciousness is not an earnest about
the perfection of morality it's
indicated by the fact that consciousness
shifts it away into infinity it asserts
that the perfection is never perfected
and you can get he's going to talk about
this a little bit in the paragraphs yet
to come you can get these people who
like almost make it into a fetish
self-improvement all right that would be
another way of losing sight of the whole
point of doing this it would be a way of
being less than earnest being less than
honest and engaging into someone's so
we've covered a lot of ground here a lot
of different modes of dissemblers going
on and we're left at a kind of impasse
but we're not quite done with the
section
you